and so the lie that we tell young kids
and I hear it so often it's so pervasive
that you don't even think about it
you're perfect the way you are well we
know that's a lie no one's perfect and
it's bad to tell people that they're
perfect you can accomplish anything if
you believe in yourself it teaches them
to avoid one of life's most fulfilling
endeavors which is conquering self-doubt
to achieve one's purpose or goal so a
couple things I know we we often talk
about some of our macro issues here in
the in the close this is one thing that
I noticed in talking with them younger
relative I will say I don't know if I
say nice if I say nephew if I say cousin
and I never like it's me and they gonna
get man it's not with your parents so I
hear this a lot less quickly in
children's shows and you hear on radio
we're constantly told for as long as I
can remember certainly our entire
upbringing that the most important thing
you can do is believe in yourself right
that's the mantra that we hear and it's
usually married with you can accomplish
you could accomplish anything if you
just if you just believe in yourself
it's it's the most important thing is
that you believe in yourself and then
you would accomplish anything you put
your mind to all right I'm gonna tell
you that neither of those statements are
true that's not a bad thing because you
know what it's okay it's okay to be
unsure of yourself it's okay not to know
now it's not okay to let that overtake
you to paralyze you to prevent you from
doing the work that has to be done
anyway but it is okay to be unsure of
your abilities here's something else you
can still accomplish by the way great
things without entirely believing in
yourself sometimes your greatest
accomplishments come in an environment
in an incubator of self-doubt now notice
I didn't say self defeat so I don't want
to say people are telling you to believe
in yourself and you shouldn't believe in
yourself no that's not what I'm saying
doubt is a very different animal from
defeat doubt is not a guarantee of
failure it's just a healthy skepticism
of this notion that we're taught of a
guaranteed victory because you know what
doubting yourself does do you know what
does well if you're a productive person
a person who utilizes critical thinking
you're going to set out to determine
whether that doubt is valid it's the
absolute confidence to believe in
yourself if you buy that wholesale it
breeds complacency healthy self-doubt
breeds inquiry it breeds vigilance also
something else self-doubt usually only
enters into the equation when it's a
decision of consequence when it's an
action worth deliberating you don't tend
the struggle with self-doubt when i
picking avocados out at the market that
was that one ripe enough I think I'd
better go back now some of you some of
you may okay something because you're
OCD so this segment is not for you you
should go touch every northern facing
corner of your house right now while
avoiding all the tile correct otherwise
your family will die but for the rest of
us that trepidation that self-doubt it
only comes into play when we're nearing
the perimeter of something that matters
especially if it's your purpose and
we've talked about this talked about
living your purpose talking about
fulfilling your purpose because everyone
has something that they're great at and
so the lie that we tell young kids and I
hear it so often it's so pervasive that
you don't even think about it you know
some of us don't even think to go on a
second is that true just like you're
perfect the way you want well we know
that's a lie no one's perfect and it's
bad to tell people that they're perfect
you can accomplish anything if you
believe in yourself the most important
thing is that you believe in yourself to
lie and that's a lie that we tell young
kids it teaches them to avoid one of
life's most fulfilling endeavors which
is conquering self-doubt to achieve
one's purpose or goal and I wish I could
say you know on a personal I wish I
could say that I always believed in
myself
life would be a lot easier it's not true
constantly had self doubts by black self
belief constantly have thought of myself
as under-qualified undeserving
overwhelmed I still do by the way
struggle with it every single day but it
doesn't stop me from doing what it is
that I know needs to be done there's no
shame we talked about this this idea of
shame and culture but the problem is we
want to praise the wrong things and
remove shame from things that maybe
should be shamed
there should be no shame in self-doubt
there's no virtue an absolute unfettered
self-confidence there's no shame in self
doubt whatsoever just as there is no sin
in fear I'm gonna go a little bit a
little bit theological on you here we've
often heard I had a pastor I've talked
about this who once taught that fear is
the opposite of love it's not hate it's
fear to be fair it might have been Rob
Bell I have no idea
could be a heretic what we're taught
that's a lot that you shouldn't fear
it's the stupidest thing I've ever heard
in my life
so let's you even if you don't believe
I'm a Christian I make there make no
bones about it but let's just say you
think it's a you think it's an Aesop
fable okay Jesus was sinless otherwise
there's no point to the story that's the
whole idea behind the Christ have you
read about Jesus in the garden before
the crucifixion he asked God if there
was any other way any other way for this
to occur to please let this cup pass
from him that was fear but there wasn't
another way and so he took that hard
path just the same see self-doubt fear
how you feel
it doesn't determine your actions and
your actions determine who you are your
actions are what define you I would even
go as far as to say that the most people
with the most absolute self-confidence
tend to be buffoons and the greatest
folks to have done anything and they're
chosen and ever they almost all have a
healthy level of self-doubt do me a
favor actually let's do this little
thought exercise here I want you to
think of a historical figure who you
really respect you admire even a great
athlete I want you to picture someone in
your mind someone who's the greatest who
ever done X okay take a second pause if
you have to do you have it okay now I
want you to go research that person find
some interviews or find some candid
writing about how they felt before some
of their greatest accomplishments
Winston Churchill could be Abe Lincoln
Marcus Aurelius could be George st.
Pierre could be Richard Pryor every
single one of them without exception
struggled with self-doubt every single
one of the greatest to have ever done X
or Y or Z was nervous and struggled with
self-doubt they didn't walk on stage
whether it be the global stage the
comedy stage or the arena like some pink
song who thinks that they are perfect
the way they are and that they had
absolute self-confidence now on the flip
side think of the buffoons think of the
people you don't necessarily have a ton
of respect right like the cast of Jersey
Shore c-level actors the mediocre
plus-size Instagram models a guy you
knew from high school who still living
in his senior year think of anyone who
you you wouldn't want to emulate they
tend not all of them they tend to be the
people who have ultimate self confidence
and this unwavering self belief doubt
never even enters into the equation
why is that who would you rather be so
the final exercise I want you to do this
week it's just a mindful is just about
being mindful I want you to think about
what it is that gives you self depth
what is it that you would like to
accomplish but maybe you're not sure if
you can or maybe if you can't think of
it I want you to be hyper vigilant and
just throughout the entire week be as
aware as you can hyper village like this
entire week so that any situation that
arises as you approach it and if you get
that when you get that little feeling
that voice in your head telling you I
don't I don't know I don't think you can
do it is that voice popping up because
you're coming close to fulfilling your
purpose I want you to ask yourself is
that voice coming up because this is
important this is a consequence this
involves your life's potential have you
been avoiding it because it might sting
you've been cutting that feeling that
voice a wide swath avoiding I want you
to be honest with yourself
here's that you don't have to believe in
yourself full-stop you don't I think
it's foolish to self doubt is normal
it's healthy you just don't have to let
it batter you into self defeat and all
of this starts with living and truth not
your truth but truth hey you know the
drill just click one of these other
videos in a box playing up here and I
mean there's an actual box I don't of
course mean that in the feminine it's a
slur but that of course I don't mean box
because men can have boxes too and I
don't mean to say box I just that men
can there's like a DC outlet an AC
outlet and they can be either one that
they choose depending on the electrical
current or fats charge of ions I think